[Music]
do you think maybe your trouble with
women it all stems from your twitter
profile picture let's put this up this
is your twitter profile picture
now first of all i want to point out
that is not you so why is that your
twitter profile picture i mean what's
going on there how can you not have that
as your twitter profile
should i start listing the reasons
the amazing thing was i was in korea uh
last year and i was walking around the
uh uh the market with my friend and i
saw that and i was like oh it's
underwear but then you're like okay this
is ridiculous because they made this guy
pose in such ridiculous underwear to
begin with yeah but then why is he doing
this yeah put that up why is he doing
that
like if you're gonna do that be manly or
something and just like just stand but
he's doing one of these guys
what do you mean what you're saying one
of these like that old move yeah you
know no i don't know what that
you know what is that like it's a very
old-timey lady thing yeah
and also look at up above the belly
button goes the waistband
like who wears the their underwear that
you might as well pull it up to the
nipples it's it's
you know if we look at it one more time
it's going to get pervy so
he's got to read it
so that's your that's your twitter
profile photo and maybe that's going to
interfere with your love life a little
bit maybe i've got when i put that up i
remember everybody was like what the
hell is that take that off please yeah
but now
never yeah
never
you make really good decisions
now are you into halloween are you a
halloween person you're gonna get
excited about it and uh you know you're
on kind of a sci-fi show do you think
you'll you'll have a cool halloween
costume i hate halloween you hate
halloween i hate halloween uh i've i've
yet to wear uh i've it's been so long
since i wore like a full costume like
couple years ago i wore one because
people were like hey don't don't let us
down it's halloween it's all have fun so
i put like a mustache and i was like hey
i'm steve with the mustache because i
couldn't really grow and then right but
a long time ago i had a traumatizing
moment uh my mom made us these
extravagant amazing
costumes where it was like this felt
dragon my brother had one and we were
all decked out and she put like you know
eye makeup and like lipstick and rosy
cheeks and it was it were kids so are
you a dragon or cher i don't know
it was like a fashionable dragon okay
and how old were you at the time uh i
was like eight okay and my younger
brother was like six okay and uh i
remember we were at my cousin's house in
michigan and uh uh
i fell asleep right before they all left
and nobody woke me up
no you see nobody will you're in your
your your dragon costume you pass out i
passed out because i'm a tired kid yeah
kids are tired sure nobody woke me up i
wake up to the noise of
my aunt
washing the dishes while clank like the
clinking of of dishes it's seared into
my brain i wake up and i'm like oh
what's going on right emo where did
everybody go they all went
trick-or-treating had been two hours
passed and so i imagine me i'm in a
dragon costume
i went on a rampage
and broke
things at my aunts i was just like yeah
yeah
like just like knocking over her vases
and stuff like she has so many vases
just knocked him over like just like ah
i'm freaking out and
after that i was like
first of all you freaked out and you
start smashing things and you're dressed
as a dragon
it doesn't help that i'm asian so that
joke really flies to the godzilla bit
yeah
but wow so that traumatized you and
you've never gone back well yeah i mean
they came back and they're like oh split
the candy with steven it's like that's
the most insulting thing you can do
i'm not gonna get your tainted dirty
pillowcase candy
i want that pillowcase your pillowcases
what do you guys use no that's a
standard thing pillowcases
i always got the plastic pumpkin with
the little face on the pores
your parents didn't mind you getting
beaten up
[Applause]
that explains it